america is struggling with racial
inequality
and health disparities in this pandemic
so this morning
we're looking at the importance of
diversity in the medicine field through
the eyes of an african-american
neurosurgeon in training
we met him before covid19 gripped the
nation only about five percent of u.s
doctors are black
that's one out of every 20 as adriana
diaz shows us that lack of diversity can
affect patient care adriana good morning
good morning not only are black doctors
such a small percentage of physicians
black men are especially
underrepresented listen to this
medical school attendance for black men
actually dropped
39 percent since the mid-80s so the
doctor that we met here dr aaron palmer
he's a minority within a minority
his is just one man's story and it's a
story
of resilience before the sun
even touches the chicago horizon dr
aaron palmer is rising to meet his day i
usually wake up between 4 15
4 30. at northwestern memorial hospital
he's training
in neurosurgery one of only two black
neurosurgeons out of dozens in his
department
nationwide only 1.3 percent are black
i often get confused with housekeeping
transport you name it i often have to no
i'm
you know your doctor taking care of you
really yeah
there aren't a lot of people of color
that are physicians
especially black men i think that is
something that
that needs to change dr babach duromi
who trains dr palmer
says he sees the benefit of diversity
every day
working with aaron is a joy because he
knows where
our patients are coming from and our
patients trust our team more
black patients are 37 percent less
likely than white patients to say they
trust their doctors
one reason the tuskegee syphilis study
from
1932 to 1972
the government experiment deliberately
left black men with syphilis
untreated many died research shows that
black patients receive
poorer care even less pain meds than
white patients
but preventive care improves when black
patients see
black doctors motivation is not enough
it's dr william mcdade's job to help
more minorities
make it in medicine as the head of
diversity for the national committee
that oversees medical training
there are economic disadvantages that
have to be overcome there are
educational deficits that have to be
overcome
and a structural racism that exists
within society that actually
carries into medicine as well he says
children of color
also need to see doctors who look like
them something dr palmer and his brother
tim
did not have back in akron ohio where we
grew up at
no one's a doctor no one's a lawyer no
one's
a judge their parents raised five kids
in a two-bedroom house
this is the home that we grew up in it's
all torn down now
as his mother amy recalled i had to
teach my kids not to pick up syringes
when they saw him on the sidewalk
and that is not an exaggeration but like
many
low-income kids of color he lacked
resources and mentorship
until his college professor ann capilla
gave him textbooks and confidence dr
palmer
we arranged a reunion more than a decade
after a pivotal meeting that's the first
time i've called you that
i was probably expecting her to say it's
not something that's going to happen for
you
but she said and i'll never forget this
she said
of course i think you can do it how
important is it to hear someone say
you can do it that moment is the reason
why i'm
actually standing here with her support
he got into
medical school but four years later no
residency program
accepted him you have a medical degree
correct without
anywhere to go correct dr mcdade says
medical students of color
often struggle with isolation imposter
syndrome and standardized testing
and are more likely than whites to not
get into residency or not complete
residency training
but dr palmer tried again and
northwestern
said yes you look great my name is aaron
palmer i used to live in that blue house
over here
i'm down in chicago now if you're a
surgeon yeah operate on the brain it's
fine
what would your 10 year old self think
of someone like you
poor little 10 year old aaron would his
mind would be blown
now he's the role model his neighborhood
never had
it's a pleasure thank you
and dr palmer is paying it forward he
mentors younger students
and is researching racial disparities
but make no mistake the state of
diversity and medicine
is dire the percentage of black and
latinx doctors
has hardly budged in the last 15 years
vlad a mentor is someone who helps you
find the hope within yourself adriana
thank you so much what a wonderful story